[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello everyone I'm fantastic and I am a
grifter I want to welcome you to
grifters Anonymous thank you for coming
to this meeting a surprising showing
actually so I'm happy to see that I know
that there's a j/s meetup in town so
this is not that we're gonna talk about
stealing things from people who can
afford to lose them so my grifter story
starts in 2011 I was working at a small
three-person company the three people
were my dad Doug and myself I was doing
accounting business management type
stuff and I was right around the kind of
crash of the American economy
and our business was going down and I
thought well you know for sure I'm gonna
have a problem I'm gonna have to find a
new job but surely I won't go out get
laid off before Doug right to my
surprise and disappointment I did and if
you've never been laid off by your
father before Doug it's an emotionally
distressing experience so um it was
followed by another emotionally stressed
Express another emotional experience was
I found out that I had spent all this
time working on my my dad's company and
I was at this point unemployable
effectively I had some good business
experience but not a lot of great
business experience and this was at a
time where people with master's degrees
and finances were getting kind of
swooped up for like a quarter on the
dollar in terms of salary so this was a
this was a bad time for me I had been on
unemployment for about six months and I
started to think seriously about what
else
I might be able to do and so got a new
slide up so this was all the time that I
had heard that anyone can code as the
rat says here and I thought well maybe
maybe I could maybe it could I had a
very bad experience with code in middle
school I took one computer science class
where we learned like C++ and Java
I say learned they learned stuff I
cheated the whole time
I just took I just bribed my fellow
students and I took their Tower of Hanoi
problems and then just kind of renamed
the variables and submitted them as my
own but it all came to a head when our
final project was this blackjack app and
I had an C I had created it in such way
where I didn't implement any logic in
terms of hitting or standing I just
looked at the users hand and decided
whether or not I was going to hit or
stand based on how close they were to 21
my teacher did not find this interesting
or amusing it at least and I said you
know I'm a pragmatist so I can I do so
good question real quick question for
you who has lied on a resume now I want
you to be super honest I want you to
kind of like think for a little bit like
no one hopefully no one who hired you is
here so who has lied at some point on a
resume okay that's not enough hands I
think some of you were lying right now
I'm gonna define lying a little bit I'm
putting something on your resume that
you have not actually like gotten paid
to to do so like if I put Oh camel on my
resume I I might be inclined to because
I'm played with it but like I haven't
gotten like paid to do it my resume is
full of that [ __ ] so I want to tell you
a little bit about a little story about
how I kind of like came into programming
this is gonna be a lot of stories very
shy on the code so um I hope not to
disappoint you when so I was coming off
the six months of unemployment and I was
desperate
I had
I had just been married so I'd been
married for a little bit but I had a
wife at a mortgage I had a brand-new kid
and I was like freaking the hell out
like what am I gonna do and so I thought
okay so I'm gonna try to figure out this
code thing and I've been working from
time to time to try to learn some new
things and then I went for my first kind
of like big pants job where I was gonna
go get paid a salary to work as a
developer it was kind of entry-level so
is HTML CSS and this proprietary
language they were gonna teach me so
this is perfect it's perfect for me and
I went for it with a friend of mine who
happened to me I'm better qualified than
me
had more experience than me better
experience there were a couple rules so
I thought well maybe we'll both get it
he'll definitely get it but I'll maybe
I'll get it too he didn't get it and we
started to kind of like process us
through I was like what like why like
why is it that I got this and you didn't
and so we started talking about this and
it came down to came down to a t-shirt I
said okay so so what did you wear to
this interview how do you how do you
like prepare would you prepare because
I'd been like going to meetups trying to
figure out like how nerds talk and stuff
like that and and and he's like well you
know like I I shaved my shaved my beard
I got a nice haircut and I wore a suit I
was like oh no dude you did it all wrong
it was like I went into that meeting not
knowing [ __ ]
but like I just wore converse jeans and
a t-shirt and like I I named that
culture fit and this became like a cheat
code for me I realized that so much of
like being hireable in tech right now is
like looking and fitting the part now
this kind of like came came came to bite
me but one of the things that I learned
early on is that the kind of main export
of a tech nerd is pedantry you just have
to give a [ __ ] about something that
nobody else cares about so like tabs
versus spaces right like it doesn't
matter
at all um but it's something that we
care deeply about we want to like make
sure that like our underdog opinion is
like validated even though both seem to
be the underdog opinion
now as I invested in my kind of sense of
pedantry I kind of made I made one
little misstep I my wife it was her
birthday and it was like kind of like a
week of and she's telling me like you
know I want to do is it's like have
Girl's Day and we're gonna like you can
move the TV you know put it on this like
you know vanity well watch Gilmore Girls
all day and there was like it's like
like I knew that I had kind of like
leveled up because there was this like
block right here and like this this
request very like a simple honest great
request I came in and I just deflected
it I saw it fall to the ground I said I
said you know the structural integrity
of that vanity seems really questionable
there's no way it's gonna hold our 60
pound TV she like this rage started to
like just come up in here she's like get
out of my house like I did not marry one
of those Big Bang Theory nerds and so
what part of me was like oh man like I'm
super sad I disappointed my wife well
then the other half is like yeah and so
then but I mean it gets worse because
then I'm like like well actually like
that's kind of a misconception because
like Big Bang Theory nerds you're like a
bad depiction of science nerds and I'm
more like a HBO Silicon Valley a nerd so
does that change how you feel at all it
did not so what I've learned from my
experience over the years is the more is
caught than taught and bad habits spread
pretty quickly and I learned this as I
was kind of making that transition into
being a more senior engineer and really
what that comes down to is like now
instead of like kind of just having like
a bunch of opinions about and being able
to do like base level tasks kind of like
think more globally about your
applications and the products that
you're working on
and it came to a head as I was watching
Netflix's chef's table episode of Dan
barber know this man is an amazing chef
absolutely incredible and he's really
more of like a food philosopher than
anything else I definitely definitely
recommend watching this episode he's
very like soft-spoken thoughtful poetic
about his his work he's doing amazing
things he has his own farm and they're
really investing in like kind of how we
think and work with food now he's really
amazing you're watching the first like
maybe 10 minutes of this episode you're
thinking wow what an incredible person
like I thought all chefs were [ __ ]
and then they show footage of him in the
kitchen and he like every other chef is
a monster just like I mean just one of
the worst that I've ever seen just a
total train wreck in the kitchen
so as good documentarians they asked him
they say you know we're talking to this
guy and he's super like sweet thoughtful
nice poetic and then on the other hand
like we see you in the kitchen and you
were just a beast I need he kind of sits
back thoughtfully for a second and says
you know the way I'm in the kitchen is
abhorrent but that's how I learned you
know from the people who mentored me and
that's how they learned from the people
that mentored them and I don't know how
to do any different and I was just I was
just weeping as I was watching this
because I was like it me it me I feel it
and I think that's so often in this
industry we front with certainty we want
to feel smart and to feel like we know
the answers and to be certain about the
things that are ahead of us this is how
we nail job interviews this is how we
you know continue to progress in our
career etc and we use this certainty as
a cheat code we love to find like best
practices and patterns that we can use
and apply this allows us to like feel
really smart in a lot of situations
unfortunately in my
case and meant that skill was outpacing
experience I had a lot of opinions on
things that I had not actually earned
experience in and this is problematic
now I'm about to offend maybe half of
you this is a lot like religion my early
religious experiences were were such
that I grew up Baptist and there was
such that everything was a sin or on the
front steps of a sin and the only way
that you could make it to heaven was to
never even get close to anything that
kind of looked like a sin but if you if
you were successful in that then like it
was like guarantee you were like you
were gonna go no problem
now I'm gonna offend the other half of
you um I think that all of us in this
tech field are religious about something
so maybe you were atheist agnostic not
not religious at all I think that we as
a culture have very strong and religious
opinions about the way that we develop a
code the way that we write it and the
way that we treat people when they don't
write it the way that we think it should
be written and lately we've been
starting to teach this to our robots
so now you can have blazing fast
religious criticism right into your
editor and as religious organizations
we're always on the hunt for a villain
we always want to find the bad thing
that's kind of caught the source of all
of our problems and never is it internal
we never look inside we say that it's
the customer the p.m. the owner of the
company the stakeholders we always want
to look externally that they're the
problem all of these unpredictable
sources of change that's what that's the
problem with our app if we could just be
certain and know exactly how we're
moving forward then everything would be
great
that's not how applications work so I
want to tell you right now it's okay to
be uncertain whatever level of
experience you're at it's okay to be
uncertain
honestly the greatest leaps in my career
have been
when I walked into uncertainty not
knowing what the answer was going to be
and kind of figured it out as I went
along there are no Universal rules so I
want to illustrate this it might be kind
of hard to see so so I'll illustrate it
verbally as well so this is who's who's
heard about dry code don't repeat
yourself yeah okay I'm gonna suing
everyone most of the hands went up but I
think most of you have heard about it so
um dry stands for don't repeat yourself
and this is one of the kind of first
tenets of clean great code that you
learn early on now we had a mentor come
into our company and start to talk with
us about how to make like really
adaptable agile code and this is
something that she said over and over
again as we presented some of our
solutions to theoretical problems that
were like just perfectly well abstracted
she would say that code looks so dry
that it chafes now if you're like a
runner or a cyclist like you know about
chafing it's not fun um and so I wanted
to kind of like illustrate this with
play-doh so here I have some brand new
out of the container of play-doh and
it's like very pliable it's very like it
doesn't put up a lot of fight when I try
to change its shape I can make this be
whatever I need it to be now on this
side I have some dry play-doh
now unfortunately play-doh has gotten
really good and I thought two days out
would make it very dry but it only kind
of made it kind of dry so um hopefully
this will be enough um as I so this
resists me so as I try to like squish it
it resists and if I really try to push
it you can see like cracks start to form
this is really it's it's very resistant
to the change that I'm trying to apply
to it so it kind of wants to stay in
this shape you can see you wanted to say
that does the purpose of design is to
allow you to do design later and its
primary goal is to reduce the cost of
change and in that sense dry is dead
something that's been dried out we
oftentimes have the experience of having
to rehydrate it in order to make it
in order to change it to make the thing
that it now needs to be when we get new
constraints and inevitably we will get
new constraints this is the way that
that software works this is how our
businesses and applications grow and
there's a context for all of these rules
these strong tenets of code and they can
be more or less divided into two
categories things that we know and
things that we don't know things that we
know become naturally stable and things
that we don't know need to remain
pliable for as long as possible where we
get into trouble is when we try to like
take rules from one side and use them on
the other so an example is dry write dry
is great in some cases we want a hat
like you can't build a castle I guess
you can't build a castle out of play-doh
right you need stones you need hardened
stones that's good when we move that to
things that need to change things that
were uncertain about well that becomes
really that becomes bad it becomes hard
to change those things if they're dried
out another thing is readability
readability is awesome on things that
we're uncertain about and need to change
regularly but it can become a liability
in in parts of our code that are
hardened and I say that because while
readability is always good sometimes it
does take a second third or fourth seed
to things like performance and when you
try to like re readable performant code
you actually make it worse so in that I
believe that components are our
architecture now you can sub that for
modules if you're not a front-end
developer however most of my experiences
in the front-end space modules are
really fascinating we have these a lot
in in music and music provides a
beautiful illustration for this in a lot
of musical systems like a modular system
in music production you have a lot of
black boxes and these black boxes are
composed together to get a new sound
each of these boxes the implementation
is hidden from you and you have just an
interface to kind of control the you
know
the parameters of that and these modules
can come from very disparate places they
can come from different manufacturers
that can have very different things but
as long as they have a single
responsibility and they have a common
interface well they can all work
together to create a new sound and if
something burns up or you decide that
you don't like this part of your sound
you don't have to replace the whole
thing you can just pop out the part that
doesn't work and replace it with
something else you love Mikey no
Photoshop there it's so photorealistic
what I've done and so what I want in my
code is not so much that it's clean but
that it has well-defined interfaces that
everything can be hot swappable I have
these hot swappable black boxes that I
can compose in neat ways and once we
have that clean code really just becomes
fashion a lot of these rules that we
have for like where semicolons should be
and spaces should be and like how many
variables should be defined on which
lines and all that stuff becomes really
less important when you think about code
like this in terms of interfaces so I
want to present to you four tenets or
things to think about to make code like
this and I call this hot garbage
architecture so the first thing is the
code should be pliable one of the things
that I see more often than not is this
this idea of speculative generality so
you you know that you need to make a
modal and so you go in you're like modal
Jas right like you just claimed the
namespace this is gonna be the modal for
now and forever everything is gonna use
this thing and we're always wrong every
time maybe you kind of got it a little
bit right but like it's it's never
perfectly right it's like hole-in-one
odds right yeah we're gonna be playing
golf tomorrow or some of us are and it'd
be like trying to optimize your golf
game around getting hole-in-ones well
you can just be [ __ ] on the field the
rest of the time but as long as you get
a number of hole-in-ones right like
you're really crushing it it's not how
golf works and I see this a lot I try
not to pick on like
specific libraries but this is one that
look really kind of hurts hurts code
regularly that I've seen and this is
some so yes lint plugin react if you're
a reactant developer there's a whole
bunch of kind of pedantic rules that
don't seem to kind of be based out of
kind of a philosophy about code really
but just the fact that there is a
natural state and so maybe we should
define a kind of like a stricter state I
guess
so one of these is like one component
per file and that just ops you out of
modules altogether which seems crazy and
so the second thing the second tenant is
composability this is what my favorite
Lego sets ever I think it used to be
like $5.00 and now it's like 35 if you
were to try to find it on the black
market
whoops Lego so my favorite thing about
this is that it's an honest-to-goodness
three in one set you don't have like a
lot of pieces left over it's like when
you tear it down and you make the new
thing it like all the pieces are used
absolutely incredible and I wanted to
bring it today but I asked my son if he
could give it to me and he said you
won't dad I'm actually experimenting
with a mono repo structure for my Lego
so I'm not sure I could find it but it's
blazing fast dad you know at least he
knows how to sell it so I see this in
react components a lot where we have a
lot of we have one component and it's
like oh cool like this is this is our
accordion this is accordion j/s we're
gonna use it everywhere but over time
you start to add a ton of like a ton of
properties for these things for very
disparate situations and each one of
these properties is it can is a
configuration now I'm not going to go
into it but the code that I prefer to
see is when we use components over
configuration we're instead of having a
lot of configuration a lot of props that
we pass down for all
these disparate situations we actually
expose like this on this Lego box tools
for creating multiple different things
so instead of instead of configuring
this one thing we say here are all the
parts you do whatever you want with it
it's gonna work and use your imagination
if you're not a react developer you're
going to give this as functions over
configuration though it doesn't have to
cease so it's less cool
the third tenet is I'm a reasonableness
my little marker on the bottom didn't
move that's sad but we're we're an
umbrella Tora Terry territory right now
so this umbrella is very reasonable it's
raining outside this umbrella is
unreasonable it's not raining outside
this one's realistic and this one is
speculative this is where it starts to
hurt
timely perf optimization is reasonable
and perf always is not reasonable so
when I teach I get this a lot I show
people how to make a click counter and
react and then I write it like this I
use an anonymous function I write set
state in line and then I just do it like
do it all right there and people who
have not actually learned enough react
to make anything say isn't this not
performant and I say well sure if you
were to make a UI like this but that
seems terrible and it's not going to
make you any money so one thing for this
is I say love your manager I know that a
lot of times we have a very tenuous
relationship with our managers and it
sucks like I get it they want they want
something for the customer and we just
want to like make sure that the code is
perfect and so they're always harsh
inner mellow I get it but managers like
see the North Star like money is always
in the North Star we need to make money
to keep doing our job the company needs
to like if we stop making money well
like the whole thing kind of starts to
collapse and also I'm gonna be honest
they know something about us too they
know that code rage is immutable
you were always gonna hate the code
that's on your screen weather like it's
written by the last idiot that touched
it or you wrote it half an hour ago
you're gonna hate it and the only real
like kind of objective tool that you can
use for like measuring like whether or
not something should be changed is
churned versus complexity
so this graph kind of illustrates that a
little bit you can google it find all
kinds of articles on it but basically if
you have low complexity or what is it
high complexity and low churn don't
touch it if you have low complexity and
high churn like don't touch it you want
to look for the outliers where you have
high complexity and high churn because
that is regularly costing you money so
finally the fourth or I'm not sure why
this is up there
I made these slides but now I'm confused
is disposability so a friend of mine
early on the first person who actually
believed that I could be a programmer
kind of told me this and it stuck with
me ever since he says we add code ask
yourself how easily it will how easily
it would be removed when you realize you
were wrong and you want to be able to
take that stuff out Oh without a trace
stupid stupid so these are the these are
the four kind of things to look out for
when you are kind of writing
architecting your code so what can I
tell you I can tell you from personal
experience I've been writing code like
this for about a year and I've become a
much happier person I've become way less
of a monster in the kitchen I've become
way less pedantic and pull requests way
more accepting of code that like doesn't
really fit my personal aesthetic and
it's made all of us more productive it's
given me a kind of a comfortable space
to be able to hear other people's input
and I've learned so much from other
people that I would have not I would
have never learned if I just shut them
out immediately on some type of
religious ideal but don't listen don't
listen to me like don't like listen to
Kent Beck Kent Beck is an amazing
program
he's been doing this thing for a long
time he is the creator of extreme
programming where he does things tests
first where he defines the interface and
then writes the code and he went on to
be some c-level engineer at a company
whose motto is move fast and break
things
so mute the thought leaders remember
that the product is just a function of
the special specification hey and we are
that function and sometimes that means
that we're just shoveling [ __ ] code from
one place to another until it all works
but green code is green code thank you
so much for coming out to this grifters
Anonymous meeting I really appreciate
your time I've been thinking about how
to work in this industry for the next 10
20 30 years happily I realized that
maybe our ideas of being a builder are
starting to fail us just a little bit we
have these ideas that we were like
engineers developers architects so we
use frameworks and scaffolding the idea
of being a builder and these
construction analogies have really
deeply integrated with code work and I
think that they're starting to fail a
little bit because we don't necessarily
build things that last 50 years a
hundred years two hundred years it's
possible that when I get back from this
trip a specification on something that
I'm working on will have changed and I
will have to rewrite the whole thing and
that's not like the [ __ ] part of the job
that is the job I think that we're more
like farmers we are farmers bump bump
bump bump yeah and the reason is we work
on living things we don't take dead
things and make more dead things out of
them like a building we take living
things and we try to make living things
out of them and cultivation is a mess so
who knows where the best fertilizer is
[ __ ] that's right
[ __ ] is the best fertilizer
I don't know why I had to put it twice I
guess it's more accessible this way so
to end my talk I wanted to be kind of
like this guy the extremely divisive so
I'm ending with a Bible verse and this
is my favorite bible verse when I have
to put something in a production now
really don't feel great about I attached
to this little verse the reference to
this verse in with a pull request where
there are no oxen the stable is clean
but abundant crops come by the strength
of the Ox now the Bible has a tendency
to put things a little bit politey um so
let me break this down for you clean
code is dead code
there's [ __ ] where money is made get it
thanks so much for your time everyone